It's rare that we only absorb about 15% of Ashwagandha that taken in powder form is this true.
So, that could very well be true.
Ashwagandha is almost always going to be in powdered form except I think Quick Silver now has a liposomal Ashwagandha.
Maybe a couple companies have a liposomal Ashwagandha.
Anything that you put in a liposomal form is going to be much better absorbed.
But all other Ashwagandha is going to be in a powdered form.
Your absorption rates of any of your nutritional supplements is not going to be like super.
So, it's you're only going to absorb so much that's why in a liposomal form you're going to be able to absorb any nutrition much better.
The negatives about well, why don't I just buy everything in a liposomal form is because the number one there's not very many supplements that are available in a liposomal form and number two they're much more expensive.
So, that's why typically they're not used. There's some supplements that are just so poorly absorbed that you know taking a liposomal form is is so much better.
It's like when glutathione came out and I don't know if it's on glutathione here, but when glutathione came out the form that it was in that just was so poorly absorbed then they came out with the acicidal glutathione.
That was much better absorbed and then the liposomal glutathione is even farly much better absorbed.